it's antibodies that protect us from the
covid virus and the latest data from the
office for national statistics
seem to offer some hope eight out of ten
adults now have antibodies most as a
result of vaccination
77 have now had one dose the rest will
have antibodies from being infected
so are we reaching herd immunity that's
when there aren't enough people
vulnerable to the virus for it to spread
through the population
and for the delta variant is likely to
be when roughly 80 percent of people are
immune
sadly we're not there yet and here's why
for a star the ons data just covers the
52 million
adults in the uk the 14 million children
and teenagers under 18
aren't currently being vaccinated but
they can still spread the virus
so even if 80 percent of the adult
population had protective levels of
antibodies
it would still be just 63 percent of the
total
uk population a long way short of herd
immunity
but there's another crucial point the
ons
test for antibodies it doesn't measure
how many people have
and that matters because the more
antibodies you have the better your
chances of stopping the infection
just look at the real world data one
dose of either the pfizer or astrazeneca
vaccine is
33 percent effective in preventing a
symptomatic infection from the delta
variant
the second dose boosts immunity raising
protection from the pfizer vaccine
to 88 percent and the az vaccine
to at least 60 percent that shows in the
infection rates
take blackburn with darwin where they're
rising fast
but only in people under 60 who are far
less likely to have had
two doses of the jab it looks like we
are now
at the start of a third wave but the
number of cases will depend on the
extent of the vaccine rollout
delaying the final lifting of lockdown
restrictions by just
two weeks would mean an extra 2.2
million people getting their first dose
and an extra 5 million
getting their second so we're not at
heard immunity yet
but the more people who are vaccinated
particularly with two doses
the slower the spread of the virus it's
one of the factors government scientists
will be considering
when they advise ministers on whether
it's safe to unlock on june
21st